hello I'm Anna styles are good guy
remembered so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of wtr AKA
was that real this is where we look at
TV shows that may be forgotten by some
but remember by others for just how
strange they were but that's it have you
ever wanted to see a show about cowboys
that were actually cows of course not
that sounds like the plot to a Happy
Meal commercial but they did it in the
cowboys and Moo mace for an idea that
sounds like dead hamburger on arrival
there was something that strangely drew
a lot of kids to it and it shouldn't
it's an awful idea
they sound like rejected villains from
the Ninja Turtle toy lineup actually
that's kind of what they were their
creator Ryan Brown was a big part of
designing several Ninja Turtle toys in
fact the Cowboys amou Mesa even make a
few appearances and other Ninja Turtle
projects now chances are it was a
similar setup as the turtles with the
toys being made at the same time as the
show as they rarely looked that much
like the original characters but the
strange thing is I never knew anyone who
played with the toys or even admitted to
watching the show it was just kind of a
strange thing to confess to but a lot of
kids must have watched it because it got
renewed for another season granted
that's only two in total but for a kid
show back then that was still pretty
impressive so why the hell did so many
of us watch it when we so easily could
just change the channel well first of
all it had a surprisingly badass theme
song I'm usually not a country person
but this song was actually kind of fun
Oh
even the opening sucks you went pretty
fast a flaming comet a mountain
exploding from the ground Cowboys on
horses with lightning striking though
you tell me if you can make sense of
what they're trying to explain here
droven
and what does any of that mean what the
hell is I had to do with bowls on horses
there's a comet at the beginning of time
it crashed into Earth fucking cows makes
sense to me
maybe this looks like the Flying
Spaghetti Monster is first-draft another
thing that I grab your attention is the
cow and cowboy is actually an
abbreviation for what you may ask like
it says in the code of the West like it
says in the code of the West like it
says in the code of the West the code of
the West says the code of the West that
the code of the West says oh ok apart
from this line being repeated as much as
with great power comes shot the fuck up
we've heard a million times why the hell
do they need an abbreviation for Cowboys
their fucking toe isn't that the whole
idea it's the thought that the real
Cowboys of the West were outlaws and
these are lawmen so it wouldn't
technically be correct we're watching a
show about fucking cowards nobody's
gonna care about the historical accuracy
as a code of the West says who the hell
even wrote the code of the West is like
the Declaration of MU dependence is it
to separate the cows who ride on horses
and the cows were actually roped and
branded yeah there's actual cows and
balls that they heard in a cattle drive
so what the fuck is going on here the
most I can gather is from this one line
seems a comment dum dum
raise new mazey from the ground we were
talking radical so the comic caused an
evolutionary shift so that some cows and
horses are people while others can be
ridden and most likely eaten like other
animal too fucking goddamn cows why helm
I think it's so hard about this with all
that said you think this show would be
really painful to watch well it was
really corny there was also kind of a
bizarre creativity and energy to it that
for a kids show in that time period
didn't make it half bad it centers
around our log Moo Montana the decoded
dude and the Colorado kid looking after
a town full of other pun names like Lily
bovine Cody calf and Cowell Amity Kate
the mayor of the town
Oscar Boulogne just stick with it he's
in cahoots with another villain named
sheriff terror bowl trust me just stick
with it
who terrorizes the talent as the masked
Bowl dealing money and hatching up
schemes to get the corrupt mayor more
moolah first off it's nice that there's
a kid show that's actually a Western
again these be everywhere a long time
ago but then they kind of went out of
style so even that had to come back in
such a strange way it was kind of nice
to see but one of the reasons Western
kid shows aren't seen as much as the
heroes oftentimes have to use guns which
in PC times is very frowned upon their
way around it
they don't use bullets yeah their ammo
actually all uniquely connects to their
personalities
for example the marshal shoots golden
stars the sheriff shoots a whip and the
gamblers shoot poker items it makes his
little senses anything else but again it
was kind of creative well connected to
their personality traits leads to
another strength of the show their
personalities yeah a lot of them are cut
outs but even it's cut outs go very kind
of entertaining the Dakota dude was
funny in his minimal dialogue he
appreciates a lady who could teach you
something yeah like his old schoolmarm
yeah taught him everything you know sure
did calamity came was a cool cowgirl
with a dictionary of weird insults
yes pat him sad wander drop whiskered
stripey pants son of a gun
then there was a lot of fun and how
politically corrupt he was
something calamity like maybe everything
you own and even the kid as kid
characters went back then wasn't really
that annoying asleep and deputy can't
avoid bad rooms all right it's deep son
most kids side characters are asking to
be shot out of a cancer it feel candid
but this one was actually pretty
tolerable
okay now Gosselin good but not short
round annoying don't I the only one who
swears calamities his mother there is
way too much resemblance there I'm
waiting for no bull on a white horse it
also taught kids a very unique lesson
that being don't always trust Authority
they never got enough evidence to put
the sheriff or the mayor away but they
never gave up in stopping their schemes
and fighting for what was right it was
an anti law as obviously our heroes are
on the side of the law but it wasn't
saying blindly trust your government
either it's kind of rare you see a show
for little kids that says don't always
trust the law magic Kevin my rate for
them there's a lot of action a lot of
jokes a lot of good voice acting did
somebody say Tim career and who is this
lovely and that was I love whose beauty
makes the sun's res pay for late hard a
bit of fun it was exactly that a bit of
fun looks like they might hit ground and
moist grass medic don't
Oh cactus Canyon so if the show was
surprisingly kind of decent how can we
lost interest in only two seasons I can
only guess but my thought is the second
season got a little too silly even for
an idea that was already silly to begin
with on top of the animation looking
like it got a budget cut there was a
bigger focus to introduce a lot more
villains and it started to become
overload most of them look like they
were made not to have interesting
personalities but instead probably sell
more toys and given the time period that
this came out that seems more than
likely but for the first season this was
actually an OK show again for kids
there's not too much in it for the
parents imagine something not quite as
good at the Disney Afternoon
but kind of in the same vein it's cute
innocent and didn't seem half-assed they
tried to make the best with what seems
like a limiting idea and for what we got
it was kind of entertaining okay I'm not
gonna demand it return to TV or anything
but it was a fun if not strange little
show they looked a fun market our
memories it's definitely worth getting
roped into
the lawn and
Oh plus it made for a very entertaining
arcade game called The Simpsons oh come
on how you die in a dream I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember so you don't
have to part never made sense to me
marshal moon would be furious